so Disney announced that the character
Lefou in Beauty and the Beast is a gay
[Music]
if I can't sit through a movie with God
or Jesus sitting by me then I got no
business showing it outside of the
liberal media a lot of good folk are
commending me on my stands to be in this
movie so I thought I'd take this
opportunity to let people know about the
other films I've wanted to ban we'll
start at the top obviously Harry Potter
cannot show that film witchcraft has no
place in any school Moana had to ban it
Oh sinéad no person mountains a new lady
Zootopia also Disney gazelles aren't
that sexy animals shouldn't be depicted
so sexy Jurassic Park the earth is only
three thousand years old all those bones
are just planted by the devil star wars
ain't nothing in the stars
besides heaven frozen witches bandit
Lion King again Disney teaching kids to
run away from their family hang out with
a bunch of gays in the woods have
premarital sex then come back and you
can be king How the Grinch Stole
Christmas not one mention of Jesus
Christ in a Christmas movie can't fart
Toy Story I had to ban that one because
of communism can't be born into
occupation you can't get out of I just
can't support that try to show moonlight
people said it was important that was a
mistake
shrek forever after had to ban it it
should have stopped after three there's
a perfect trilogy really Juno I liked
that movie she kept the baby that's the
right thing to do had to ban it because
they gave her a choice Pocahontas
demonizing humans Monsters Inc
humanizing demons ban dogs purpose like
I'm gonna show a movie about
reincarnation and animals having souls
No thank you death Mad Max present this
idea that all these fossil fuels will
lead to some sort of desolate landscape
yeah that's real that's real Planet of
the Apes I want to get started out of
this movie but I'm gonna have to people
think that humans came from monkeys look
at our monkey and look at me he used a
look like a monkey no sir no sir
finding dory you didn't find another
theater good luck finding one get out no
sir
great wall now see I thought that one
was gonna be about the important wall
but it turns out it's about Matt Damon
with a ponytail save the Chinese from
the lizard lizard people good movie
I didn't man enough I like my baby